hey what's up everybody uh i just want
to tell you real quick i got
uh the message today from tom segura
asked me to do the bream problem with
him this week so
starting uh wednesday through sunday
i'll be at the brea improv with tom
segura it's gonna be a great time if
you're local come out
we're gonna have a lot of goddamn fun
all right uh this episode
of the honeydew was brought to you by
policy genius me undies and expressvpn
more on that later
let's get into the do the honeydew with
ryan zickler
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com
ryan sickler on all social media uh i
just want to say thank you for your
support you guys send me so many
messages every week
dms emails all of it i sincerely
appreciate you guys the community is
growing and growing please subscribe to
the youtube
uh let's get those numbers up over there
and if you
want another episode a week subscribe to
the patreon community that thing is
growing and growing
there are so many wild [ __ ] stories
out there
and they're still coming i got emails
just sitting and waiting where i'm like
jesus christ we got to get this person
on
uh it's five bucks a month that's it one
flat fee if you sign up for a year or
more you'll get over a month of free
episodes
um and if you or someone you know just
has that [ __ ]
story that needs to be heard please
submit it at honeydewpodcast
gmail.com all right that's the biz you
guys know i record here at the santa
monica music center
unfortunately as you know been closed
down for quite some time but they are
still offering online music lessons you
can still come in and get music
instruments or get your instruments
served
uh purchase whatever you want if you go
to santa monicamusic.com use the code
honeydew the wave the registration fee
and they
will give you one free lesson when you
sign up for a package
that's it all right now you know what we
do here we highlight the low lights
we uh shine a little light in that
darkness and
laugh in the face of trauma we're over
here you know
doing things and solving problems i'm
very excited for this guest over here
first time
on the honeydew ladies and gentlemen
please welcome sarah colon everybody
welcome to the honeydew sarah thank you
ryan thank you
thank you for being here nice
introduction i appreciate that that's uh
thank you haven't heard an applause in a
long time you know
i know right clap for yourself girl here
[Laughter]
before we get into what we're going to
talk about today will you please
plug promote everything you'd like yes
uh obviously tour dates are
who knows right now they're some are
scheduled some are not
some are cancelled some are not
absolutely some may not so you can keep
an eye on those on sarahkalona.com
dot com and also has the links to both
my books
which you can buy through my website and
they're on amazon and you can
binge two and see two seasons of
insatiable on netflix or the last two
seasons of shameless that i was on and
yeah that's fun for everybody that's
awesome if you're not
leaving the house you can read or watch
tv that's it there you go
um so i'm interested to talk to you
about this because you
are a guest who has more of a story than
a life story we're gonna talk about
today
um but first where are you from
originally um i grew up in arkansas
oh wow okay arkansas farmington arkansas
and you say grow up so how long were you
there
i was there from five years old until i
graduated college until i was 21.
you go to university of arkansas as well
yeah you're a razorback i sure am oh
[ __ ]
yeah all right i had a plastic hog hat
and everything did you who was uh like a
premier athlete
when you were there um like who'd you go
did you go to games scotty thurman
basketball player corliss williamson um
i didn't pay enough attention to
football at the time
yeah you did have good basketball yeah
they actually they won the championship
when i was i think it was like 94.
okay were you there i wasn't but i was
at the on the on dixon street afterwards
where everyone
put on their hog hats and then the um
they gave out public intoxications
yeah those are a nice thing in the south
they like to give you just for walking
from bar to bar there you go and they uh
i remember when
i didn't get one but a friend of mine
did and when they went to court the
judge
fined him the score of the game
so whatever the score of the game was
that was the favorite
that's great yeah so it was like we're
celebrating but also you still have to
pay
let's keep it low scores yeah yeah very
arkansas thing to do
so i'm interested to hear about this
story um
because i know it involves pets
uh but some other things as well which
caught me off guard while i was like
whoa all right shut up and don't say
anymore
so please share away well so when i i
moved out to california in 96
right after college and i was living
with my dad he lived in orange county at
the time kind of scraping money together
to move up here
did you come here to be a comedian yes
you did okay acting comedian
writing i didn't know how it would all
go together but i wanted to do it and
stand up in arkansas wasn't a thing at
the time not in
is there a club there at all right there
i mean in i don't even think there is in
fayetteville still there's a more of a
a performance place and sometimes they
do shows there but they don't
really have any dedicated and then they
for sure didn't they didn't have any
open mics there wasn't anything so i
really didn't know how to
um get into it i just i started out here
which is kind of a weird place to start
stand up yeah it is i do too yeah
so i started going to in it was 97 i
started going to
an improv class um which i quickly
realized that was not my thing
yeah it's not the same thing people
think it's it's not and i went to the
con
the out the comedy connection
is that it yes yeah so that was
um a class that i met this guy
and we started dating
i thought we were dating we never had
sex
and okay so let's can we talk about that
a little bit because
i'm a guy who has had sex with a girl
before you have
yeah i have a couple i've been lucky and
uh i've also thought well yeah we had
sex but we're not dating
right you know what i mean and where
she's like no no we had sex
we're dating right i'm like well both of
us [ __ ] up because we should have had
this conversation before i put anything
inside
right yeah so what makes you dating but
you're not
sexually intimate so and that was that
was what was confusing probably because
i
was had had sex before that and
sometimes with people i
didn't ever care to see again or date
but this person and i
were i was very it was a little [ __ ]
in my early days
if anyone needs to know if anyone needs
to anyone needs me to clarify that
i got it all out wait can i ask you can
we talk about that for a second
what is [ __ ] what do you because
here's people ask me all the time and i
say
like look i know it's a double standard
but
to me if a woman lost her virginity at
18 let's say
and let's say she's 36 and she's not
married but she's only had
two partners a year just dated two guys
a year i don't think that's promiscuous
i don't think that's [ __ ]
i don't think there's anything wrong
with that but after 18 years
times two equals 36 partners you know
what i mean so
and some people have had some better
years than just two you know what i'm
saying
so there's been slow years there's been
good years
you know some dry spells and then i've
hit on a few you know
so what makes it [ __ ]
i don't know i mean i hate to use the
term [ __ ] because i wouldn't shame
anyone obviously but i would just say
there were so close
i'm one of them you can shave yes male
and female all around it takes two
but there was yeah i don't i don't know
if i would say numbers that i would i
don't
know don't put numbers on no that's not
also i don't ask women anymore how many
partners you've been with i've learned
because i feel like
when you're going like this i'm like
she's counting by five
yeah she is counting by five
i do ten ten twenty third notes
i'm decades i'm like seventies eighties
um yeah i don't know what i just don't
know that there is fast what do you mean
[ __ ]
probably promiscu probably how were you
when you lost your virginity i
well i was 16. okay but i was also in
farmington arkansas and there wasn't
anything else to do and i think i was
honestly in my class i was one of the
last
last at 16. yeah okay yeah
so all right i was definitely so you
were like i need to step my [ __ ] game up
i was like i guess
i guess i need a kid next year
[Laughter]
yeah i came out here i don't know there
was um
maybe mixed with just having a few too
many cocktails on my nights out and not
really knowing anyone and then being
like oh i guess i'll hang out with that
guy
and well he wants to hang out at home
tonight in his apartment
so i guess that's where we're going so
it was just a little more
free with my time gotcha
but this guy was different yeah and i
think that's the thing that strikes me
the most about this story because he
he and i spent so much time together
right off the bat i didn't know him well
he had moved here
from florida he was from chicago but he
moved here from florida
and and i met him in this class how old
are you guys at the time i was 20
it was 97 so i was 22
i wasn't 23 yet so it was and he was i
believe
24. okay so same age yeah and we just
started
i didn't know many people here obviously
and we just started hanging out
all the time i mean
days nights lunch after
class shopping together just
i spent a lot of time with this person
that i didn't know very well and so
i hadn't really been in that situation
because it usually takes me a little bit
longer
to warm up to people unless i'm just
gonna one night stand
yeah then it's like you know isn't it
crazy how much different it is so weird
like i'll [ __ ] you but i like you
yeah i'm all right come on yeah i'm
gonna take my time
but we i would i spent the night with
him a couple of times but we didn't have
sex and we didn't really we made it up
okay so elise had some intimacy it
wasn't like just
word best friends right okay but
in retrospect sometimes i look back and
like maybe he just thought we were best
friends
and then sort of like pity made out with
me or something i don't know
and then i started wondering if he was
gay because i sometimes i would just
like well obviously if somebody doesn't
want to
[ __ ] me he's gay is it ego
wonderful couldn't have anything to do
with my shitty haircut in the
fact that i smoked marble reds
it's definitely not me it's definitely
not me
but when he would make out with me i was
like this feels like a straight person
you know making out with me um not that
i actually know to say if you made out
with gay guys
and you know the diff um i guess they
did once in college
but passion just wasn't there yeah but i
didn't know again i didn't know he was
gay at the time and i i'm not sure he
did either but
felt like a regular kiss i mean who
knows but
this guy yeah we spent a lot of time
together so one night
we go out to see someone at the improv
called the hollywood improv
and do stand up now are you doing
stand-up at this point i haven't gotten
on stage yet as a stand-up i had
friends that were doing it i was still
just trying
um i was still in the improv class and i
still hadn't figured out how to sort of
i hadn't done an open mic or anything
yet so but i had friends that were doing
stand-up that i'd met and you know
either at restaurants and working in you
know bars and then
these classes so we go to see someone at
the hollywood improv and
this guy he so he didn't drink not a
draw and it wasn't
he wasn't sober because of anything he'd
never had a drop in his life
but he was really fun uh who knew he
could be fun without
alcohol yeah you guys oh it's true
yeah the rumors are true
so we after the show that we saw he
i wanted to go out for drinks with some
friends my friend that had just gotten
off stage so i said let's you know we're
all gonna go out
and he had a friend with him who had had
a couple drinks and he said i'm not
gonna
i don't feel like going out i'm just
gonna drive my friend mark i think was
his name home
and i was like okay you know are you
sure you don't want to just come out and
he's like yeah you know
probably you're going to be annoying i
think was probably his take like
he's going to stay in but then later
drive a drunk friend home is that what
he's going to be a dd for somebody i
think yeah well no he didn't he was like
we were going out and he said i'm
i'm bailing i'm going home okay and i'm
gonna take my friend that's had a couple
drinks with me so we had someone with
them
so cut to the next day we were supposed
to go to lunch and
um i'm calling him and calling him and
and he's not answering and i'm like this
is so strange he usually
you know especially i was calling him
kind of consistently at this point
because he hadn't
showed up and that was not like him and
it was just very strange
how long had you known each other at
this point um a few months
probably only
two and a half months okay yeah which
again was
that's why it was so odd how much time
we spent together and
um but again neither of us knew many
other people either so maybe it's not
that odd
but it was strange for him to not be
calling me back so
we were supposed to hang out again so
i'm calling him calling him and
and i'm thinking like did i piss him off
last night because i went out but no he
you know it was it was just that let's
either go out or not and he just wanted
to go home and he didn't seem upset
well finally uh his roommate called me
and he was like oh hey i'm you know i
see that you've been calling
neil and i said yeah what's what's going
on and he was like well
he was in an accident last night taking
him home the same guy you're talking to
no
no his he was he was taking his friend
home but this was his roommate it wasn't
the same person
um and i said all right you know where
is he i'll go
i'll go visit him and he said well no he
didn't make it no
and uh neither did the guy that was with
him oh no
both of them yeah on laurel canyon
boulevard which you know not that anyone
in the wyoming canyon windy canyon road
and uh
of all things for this guy to be hit by
a drunk driver
never had a drop of alcohol in his life
yeah drunk driver killed two people
oh and the driver lived [ __ ]
yeah actually before i came here i was
so i'd sort of just
never looked up the person that hit him
um since then at least and uh he's
i found he lives he's just you know he's
fine i mean
again he made a horrible mistake
obviously and he's in his 40s now i
don't know
but um he's still he seems to be
out and about so i don't know what
happened with his like prison sentence
or how long did he go to prison
i i don't know anything i couldn't find
anything and i feel like at that time it
was harder
to sort of follow up you know in 97 on
like cases and it's
it's not all over instagram and twitter
and everything yeah
yeah it's just a little so what is that
like what is it like to
to it's not not only did you really like
this guy like you
were probably one of the last definitely
one of the last people he saw
yeah and i just was like god if he just
would have gone with us
and you know in this weird way it's like
if you would have
if he would have gotten with us if i
could have convinced him so i sort of i
felt guilty
yeah i felt guilty even though i mean
like you could have pushed more to get
him to go with you
yeah but also what a weird thing to feel
you know like oh i should have made you
go out to drinks with me
right but there's just that what if oh
if you had
then you wouldn't have driven home at
this particular time or if we had asked
you one more time
is that 10 seconds long enough for that
drunk driver to get by you or
you know what yeah i know you could do
that yeah i hadn't thought about that
before but now
now
i hadn't really gone by the 10 second
thing but jesus christ
timing is everything as you know
oh yeah you definitely man that's
strange did you go to the funeral and
stuff or
i didn't so he had only been here
for about the same amount of time that i
knew this is every parent's worst
nightmare there it is
it is and that's what my mom said to me
so
there was this i worked at this
restaurant called mirabelle at the time
and i had a friend
i know it was one at the grove and
there's one in sherman oaks right
uh this was on sunset okay so um
it was like right next door to red rock
i don't know if you remember of course
one of the best stand-up shows back in
the day
had a lot of blackouts at red rock
unfortunately in my 20s
but um that yeah that was
a friend of mine closed down mirabelle
he was the bartender that night
and on his way home he saw the accident
because i started telling him about it
the next day and he's like i passed by
i passed by that honestly because he
lived in studio city he was going home
i'm giving a lot of logistics that your
audience is like could you please quit
talking about both no please it's
specific yeah just google map
but um yeah so he had seen
it which i just thought was strange it
was like one of my closest friends was
like i
i saw it you know i'm not everything but
he
it was closed down and he had to go
around it and blah blah blah
and then i called my mom because i you
know i was very close to her i am very
close to her and i said
i told her what happened and she said
you know this is er
this is what you said every parent's
worst nightmare this guy just moved out
to california pursuing his dreams and
he's doing the right
thing yeah he's sober and doing a solid
by taking a friend home yeah to make
sure that person's okay yeah
and then they both die yeah [ __ ] from
someone else not doing the right thing
who's still alive
yeah and on facebook yeah yeah i mean
man yeah it's very it was
uh i was just so and then i start i kind
of i'm not very
i'm not like a religious or spiritual
person very much but i
i thought oh this is why i spent so much
time with this person was because i was
only gonna have
that much short amount of time you know
and so
cut to i so i didn't go to his funeral
because i
i think his family brought him back to
chicago where he was from
um now at the time that he passed away
i was taking care of he had two cats and
his roommate that he had at the time
was allergic or something so i had his
two cats
in my house so now he's dead and i've
got
two cats and what is that weird as [ __ ]
so
i was yeah like you have this guy's cats
yeah
who i barely know can i ask you after
this does
does anything change for you or you do
drink more
do you uh become more
anti-social does anything happen are you
freaked out by this
i became a little more anti-social i
became more guarded with spending time
with
getting really close to people
especially so quickly yeah because
you're just gonna leave anyway
and it was one of the few times that i
had sort of bonded with someone that
quickly so i thought
well that's not worth it yeah
i've got friends i've known for a long
time i'll just stick with them and was
this the first
like significant death that you were
close to in your life
yeah it was yeah there's a lot that goes
into that
yeah and and especially someone young
someone so yeah
i'm young yeah and then
a couple weeks after it happened
i got a letter and i honestly
don't know how this person got my
address to this day
i don't know if his roommate somehow had
it and passed it on
but i got a letter from a girl who
said that hi i was neil's girlfriend
until
a few a few days ago yeah
did she know about you she
knew that we were friends
um and so i think she wanted to reach
out to me
i'm really trying to remember how she
got my address oh i know what it was i
got his
mom's address and not from his his
roommate
and i sent her a letter after speaking
to my mom i sent her a letter
i'm sorry this is it's been a while but
it's okay no i got
his mom's address after i spoke to my
mom from his roommate and i just sent
her a letter very
i didn't say i was his girlfriend i
didn't say you know he didn't have sex
with me so maybe he was gay i didn't say
it
i didn't say anything like that that
wasn't my official
my initial letter not in my not in my
final
a little lighter
um i said you know i just want you to
know that
in the short time neil was here he had
an impact on
several people including myself we spent
a lot of time together he was
wonderful he was driving a friend home
that night
um last i saw him he was smiling and
laughing i i didn't even know if this
was appropriate
but my mom told me that it would be i
would love i would i mean it would
crush me but it'll be one of those
things i'd be so happy someone sent me
yeah good i think so it definitely would
like
you saw my child right before they
passed and they were happy
and not you know and they were going
home doing the right thing my kid's not
drinking and driving and doing something
[ __ ] stupid you know
like the other [ __ ] is yeah yeah
which
um you know i'm sure she knew
most of that by this time but i just
kind of wanted to give her
and you know when i said i wasn't the
only friend he made in this class and i
know it's the first class he took out
here and he really impacted
you know a lot of people in there and i
also think for not only any parent but
especially for a mom
who raised a son in today's world as
much as
guys are [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] and can
be
um to hear that your son was a gentleman
and a happy person and was good to you
and stuff i think that's
that that's the stuff that mom will
remember forever
yeah yeah sure i think so too i mean i
think it
you know but hopefully it helped her
somehow and
she shared that letter with his
girlfriend that's how she got my address
now that you might
[Laughter]
remember when you were not spending time
with him i'm going to look into this
letter
so she contacted you huh so she wrote me
um and said neil's mom got your letter
it meant a lot to her
and and this is and she introduced
herself by him this is my name and i was
neil's girlfriend up until you know a
couple weeks she really wrote that
yeah that's not necessary right well is
it
i think she probably thought that
he wasn't i mean again we i guess we
never had sex but then she went up until
a couple weeks ago
because he died up until a couple weeks
ago because she realized like you were
in the picture
no she meant that's why yeah the way it
was worded was
you know that it was because he's dead
yeah yeah
not because so we broke up yeah so it's
over hard
that's what i'm saying it's a weird
thing to say
no it is he's dying so we broke up but
um you know
now that he's saying it was uh it was
very oddly worded and you said it a few
times so i know it's written in there
and you remember it i remember it very
distinctly and i
and especially since i thought well i've
never
heard of this person but she had heard
of me so he had told her that he had a
friend that was a girl
he probably didn't tell her that we had
a couple make-out sessions or whatever
but
um yeah he had told her about me and so
she said
i know that you have his cats
so and she's in florida and she said so
if you want
to send them to me and i was like what
the
how am i going to send a cat mailing
cash to florida i don't know there's two
of them you know
i didn't even know how this was possible
to try to
to get a cat tour it just seemed like a
lot more work than it would be worth and
i said it's
it's fine i'll just keep the cats it's
like kind of all i wrote her back i
didn't really know what else to say
other than i guess congratulations on
being his girlfriend and
he didn't fully cheat on you so that's
good yeah
um so it was just a strange sort of
culmination of events to find out
that he also had he'd never mentioned
her to me
and you know it is what it is obviously
but it just seemed very
strange to me and did you ever hear from
her again no
no i just said i wrote her back and i
said thanks for the offer i'm fine to
keep them if if everybody
unless his family wants them or
something and i think everybody was like
no they're [ __ ] cats nobody wants
them
yeah um and then like a two days later
one of the cats got out
and never returned so it's he probably
went to the
coyotes oh man yeah but i was kind of
glad he died before that happened
you know
he was very attached to those cats so at
least
he didn't live long enough to see me so
now
that one gets here m1 cat her down
you're like a little bit of a cooler i
feel like
john better be careful now
you know what one time i had sex with a
guy who
sorry listen i don't know what you're
about to say
but coming off the heels of what we're
talking about for you to say you know
what one time i had
sex with the guy i can't wait to hear it
he went he went missing the next day
missing well it turns out he got run
over by a bulldozer
listen i don't know anyone who knows
someone that got run over by a bulldozer
you died
yeah well no because they seem pretty
slow like you could get away from a
bulldozer yeah oh yeah
um so people he was croatian and there
was like rumors that maybe it was a
a hit none of it made any sense i mean
again i'm just hold on
all right we're not just gonna gloss
over this okay how do you
how do you meet this guy i worked with
him at a bar
and then you just go home you have sex
we yeah we worked together for several
months and then one night we just hooked
up the next day
he's gone so he left that night yeah
mm-hmm and then he went he just would
have stayed a little longer
this [ __ ] might not be dead be a
bulldozer
i mean what a way to die i gotta start
making people stay around
longer john stay put [ __ ]
say if you think oh you want to leave
well you're going to die you're going to
die bro mm-hmm
yeah the he also worked at a
construction site and then they said he
had a terrible accident he was run over
by
a bulldozer that doesn't seems like it
sounds shady
i don't care if you're the first day on
a detective case
like let's look into this did the guy
not have legs like how did he get run
over by a bulldozer
it seems on both ends that the bulldozer
could have been like hey
move i mean unless the bucket dropped
and hit him on the [ __ ] head and
knocked him but you would see that
he wouldn't just go missing yeah these
were the
who runs over somebody and then doesn't
know where the [ __ ] they are for a day
nobody said move to bulldozer i mean
this the details were very shady coming
in on this story
and believe me once as shady as they
were i was like i'm not going to ask any
more questions
because i don't want to i don't want to
be next no you ask questions about a dui
accident you don't ask questions about a
missing person yeah bulldozers no
that's between them and them yeah so but
there's a little bit of a history of me
yeah it sounds like it sounds like it's
a roll the dice to roll into hey will
you
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor policy genius
it's may which means we're already
almost halfway through this year
all right head into the summer with one
less thing to worry about make sure
you're not overpaying
for your home and auto insurance policy
genius makes it easy to compare home and
auto insurance
in one place they can help you find home
and auto coverage similar to what you
have now
but at a lower price their team will
handle the paperwork to set you up
with the new policy or switch over your
current one getting started is easy
first you head to policygenius.com you
answer a few quick questions about
yourself and your property all right i
just did this
i just went through renters earthquake
auto all of it uh you name it they'll
help you out with it and it's great to
use it's easy to use policy genius takes
it from there okay
they'll compare rates from america's top
insurers to find your lowest possible
quotes if they find a better rate than
what you're paying now they'll switch
you over
for free their top-notch service has
earned policy genius
a five-star rating across thousands of
reviews on trustpilot
and on google head to policygenius.com
to get started right now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
our next sponsor is me undies me undies
believes that comfort is about
more than what's touching your skin it's
about feeling comfortable
in your skin too that's why me on these
not only uses a sustainable breathable
soft fabric
but they also give you endless styles to
choose from it's total comfort
inside now they've sent me a few pair
now i like the boxer briefs
and they've sent me colors i would never
i got a white pair with purple trim
i would never buy that and you know what
my favorite pair i love them they fit
good
they maintain uh what um what is it i'm
trying to say they're um they're hold
all day long you know how you get like
i used to get those old school boxers
and you'd wear them and by the end of
the day the legs
look like shorts on you know these not
like that at all they're great me on
these offers
classic colors to ridiculous prints so
you can fully express yourself
in your own unique way plus me undies is
inclusive offering a range of sizes from
extra small
to 4xl never leave your couch again with
a meundies membership a monthly
subscription
that sends new pairs right to your door
with site-wide savings and exclusive
sales you'll automatically pay less
for everything meundies has a great
offer for my listeners
for any first-time purchasers you get 15
off and you get free shipping and if
you're not satisfied with any product
for any reason they'll refund or
exchange it no caveats
no questions to get your fifteen percent
off your first order and free shipping
go to meundies.com
honeydew that's me undies dot com slash
honeydew
our next sponsor is expressvpn when you
use the bathroom
you always close the door behind you
right i hope you do
you don't want random passer buyers
looking in on you so why would you let
people look in on you when you go online
using the internet without expressvpn is
like going to the bathroom
and not closing the door did you know
that your internet service provider
knows
every single website you visit and
what's worse is they can sell this
information to ad companies and tech
giants who will use your data to target
you
expressvpn puts a stop to this it
creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet so that your online
activity can't be seen
by anyone i use expressvpn on all my
devices it works on everything
phones laptops even routers so everyone
who shares your wi-fi
can still be protected even if they
don't have expressvpn i love expressvpn
to watch netflix shows that are blocked
in the us
i just watched big lebowski from
australia the other day as they have it
blocked here
got it no problem and the best part is
using expressvpn is as easy as closing
the bathroom door you click one button
and boom you're protected expressvpn is
the world's number one rated vpn by cnet
wired diverge
and countless others so if you're like
me and believe your online activity is
your business
secure yourself by visiting
expressvpn.com
honeydew today use my exclusive link
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n-d
honeydew and you can get an extra three
months for free again that's
expressvpn.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
all right so you take this guy's cats
one gets out and dies
when castell have a cat yeah so i got a
cat and
and how long does that how long do you
have that cat 16 years
holy [ __ ] from that point 16 years yeah
so wait 97 2017 i mean 2013.
talking about seven eight years ago you
did a real solid for that cash i did i
did and
we became very close i knew it much and
was much closer to that
mischief was it always mischief did you
change it
it was mischief it came uh mischief and
the one that that
went to the coyotes i believe was uh
malkie i remember that cat's name too
but mischief was this cat and a slow cat
slowly over there you got maybe melky
got run over by a bulldozer yeah he did
you can look into these things so you
had this cat for 16. how old was it when
you got it a couple years
i guess it wasn't positive but i think
he said
he was around a year or so so yeah cats
they really cling on for a while
or can um and this one
he went you know it was like i went from
my one bedroom apartment
at the time with a roommate to a
different apartment i mean this cat
lived in five apartments and then
finally um
in 2013 when i had to put him down i was
living
by myself and i had just broken up with
someone that i'd been with for five
years i was basing my only really
long-term relationship before
uh i got married i mean long-term
meaning we lived together and it
seemed like maybe it was gonna go into
marriage but then when we moved in i
wanted to get married i thought and then
when we
and he was very much dragging his feet
and then when we moved in together
that's when i was like oh i hate this
person i hate
this part i don't want to marry him i
don't even want to live with them
um i know some people have different
feelings about if you should live with
someone first but
if you can i definitely recommend it
because that's when you really find out
like that's how you brush your teeth
yeah it's all that little [ __ ]
it's all that little [ __ ] that
drives you nuts i remember one time he
got
he got hurt and he had vicodin and he
was just like complaining about the pain
and i was just like i just wanted to
stuff all the vicodin
and it may be something to mine and just
like this is why are you complaining i
mean the guy's knee was broken or
something i mean it was not it was you
know he had a reason to complain
but things like that really drive you
crazy someone
and we our breakup was it was kind of
[ __ ] i mean i was
i was over it before we broke up so it
was a little bit easier for me but he
was the person that sort of went to
oh no maybe i should have treated you
differently and
so then he kind of dragged out the
breakup and
just by the time it was finally over i
was so
relieved and i was working i was working
on
on chelsea lately at the time so i had a
full-time writing job and that kind of
came between us
because he had been the most successful
one i was always the bartender and he
was successful and then when things
changed a little bit
his attitude towards me changed wasn't
very supportive
so by the time the point being by the
time we broke up i just was so
relieved to be alone to be single i
didn't
feel like i needed anybody it wasn't a
chip on my shoulder i just was like this
who cares
if i ever meet someone this is fine i've
i can
do this all on my own it doesn't matter
but then when my cat got sick
your things like that i don't know i i
don't
if it depends on how you feel about pets
but i feel like when we're we're all
[ __ ] animal people yeah
yeah we are for sure you know i mean
like 16 years too or
whatever and the way you got the cat
like there's a whole
thing that that goes in there it's not
like you went and just
rescued this cat from [ __ ] you know a
shelter
like this is a cat that came because
someone died
yeah and it felt a little bit sort of
like oh this is there's zero connection
to this
person anymore even though i never you
know it's not like i really thought
about him
often or wrote his mom anymore or
anything but
it was just his it was it was something
i kind of took care of for him
the only thing i knew that i could do
maybe he was like making up for letting
him go home that night i don't know
yeah but i was very close to this animal
and
so when i had when they i found out he
was sick um
it's the same as probably most people
you find out how
how to keep them comfortable you
definitely don't want it to go on too
long
there's all these things go into it but
at first it seemed fine
it was it was okay it's his kidneys were
failing but they they can go on a long
time you just have to give them a little
fluid and they're comfortable and all
this stuff and i thought well that's not
a big deal
i got home from this thing that they
give me that you have to
there's a fluid thing you have to get
like an iv bag and a fluid
and inject them with a little and a shot
and all this stuff and i'm looking at it
and i'm like oh this is a
this is a two person this is a
two-person job
you know that guy shouldn't have died
and he could help me
yeah like oh you got a whole
like i don't think there's ever i can
even picture it sometimes i mean i had
to take the iv bag
hang it on a hanger and hang that on a
closet
wrestle the cat and you know get it and
then once the fluid was in he was happy
and fine and all was good but the
process of it sure yeah
it just looked like a sad you know
single cat lady movie that you would
[ __ ] write in a second like it just
seemed so
so sad and that went on for
you know for a little while it didn't go
on too long because it went on until
they
they told me uh the signs or whatever
but it was it was hard and then it was i
would
i was doing a lot of traveling for
stand-up so i would leave town and then
i would feel
super guilty that i left this animal
that i promised someone i would take
care of forever at home
while he was kind of not feeling well
and then it became well i had to put him
in a vet when i was gone
just so they could keep an eye on him in
case he needed more fluids and it just
became
like caring for like an elderly like
parent or something it just felt
very shitty and awful and
um and then when he it was time to to
put him down i had
the vet come to the house you know they
they could
yeah i mean it seems like common
practice for the most part now but i
i think it's probably like a little
costly so it's not as easy to do for
everyone but it's definitely
it made it easier because i was i had
friends over and we all kind of
said goodbye to him and um i swear to
god when i put when they put him down
i looked down and i saw tear coming out
of his eye no
yeah and then i realized well no cats
don't cry that's just it was my own
[ __ ] tear that fell off
you're crying on the cat they're laying
right here
sarah
your tear is running down the cat's
crying we're crazy
oh my god he feels it too and then i was
like oh no that's definitely
for sure one of mine uh
yeah and then i i had to put him down
and i just feel like that was
um it was sort of a weird full circle
moment but it was also one of those
moments of
this is it would be nice to have
somebody by
your side it's like it i felt that again
even though i had this in my head of
like you don't
need that and and luckily i had my
friends it's not as if i didn't have
anyone there
but the daily struggle of having an iv
hanging from a [ __ ] cabinet and you
know trying to
wrestle an animal and it just sort of
felt like
a weird closure with what happened to
him
but what happened with the cat yeah i
mean it's a long book
yeah the long book the right 16 17 years
let me ask you this when it comes to
because
you're literally being your hospice care
for the [ __ ] cat
do you start to have any feelings
afterwards like look honestly i'm glad
the cat's in a better place i don't have
to do this
[ __ ] anymore with this whole thing and
then the guilt that comes along with
feeling
better about hey everything is the way
it should be and this cat's in a better
place
a hundred percent there's there's did i
let it go on too long
and then there's oh the one time i went
out of town and then the vet called and
said he didn't feel good and i felt like
oh was i the shittiest person in the
world to you know go out of town even
though it was for work and
leave him somewhere else because i
remember that night i came home when i
picked him up from the vet and
because he had a little he just wasn't
feeling that well there and they
let me know but he was still okay and i
remember that night i came home and he
just like
laid on my chest and slept there and he
usually ran around and like opened
cabinets all night he was a real
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um but he just slept on my chest and
just basically stared at me didn't cry
he didn't cry because they don't but he
stared
right at me all night and just laid
there and purred and i was like oh this
guy is like
please don't go out of town anymore
please don't leave you know don't let me
go
don't make me go in another place or
maybe he was like please kill me please
please do this kill me come on lady yeah
yeah this
[ __ ] together figured it out yeah i mean
he was uh
like a big personality in my life which
is sometimes again feels so weird to say
but it
was a long journey so i definitely felt
guilty like did i let it go on too long
or um and then when i would feel
relieved when i would go out of town
and after 16 years of having to think
who's gonna feed him
where is he gonna go do i don't have to
hook him an iv
up to him and look like the most
pathetic person in the world anymore
um the the relief makes you feel like
[ __ ] yeah
it does doesn't it doesn't the thing
that should make you feel good makes you
feel like [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah cause you because you feel
like you shouldn't have any satisfaction
out of it
no at all goodness could become of this
yeah
and um yeah and then he
then that's it i like i didn't have him
anymore but i just it made me real uh
it did make me realize that i wouldn't
mind sharing my life with someone if
that's
it's a strange thing to come across from
having to put an animal down why did you
what made you come to that
well part of it was the fact that i i
realized it would have been
nice to have someone there when i was
going through it and when he was going
through it and
and and helped me make the decision
instead of just my friends maybe someone
that was there every day
um and also
this is gonna sound really stupid but
i'm really sad that my husband never got
to meet my cat
that's that doesn't sound stupid i'm
with you on that [ __ ] i'm sentimental as
[ __ ]
yeah yeah because i mean there was a
time i met him
uh probably six months five months after
i had to put him down for four or five
months
oh okay very soon yeah and i i mean
there was like one night i woke up in
the middle of the night crying about the
cat and he was just like whoa
this is your i was thinking about
forever
but uh you're you're real close to this
[ __ ] cat hey
you're really close to this i'm like
don't leave the bags boyfriend's
cat here don't leave the bed you never
know you never know what's gonna happen
to you
so did you hear a bulldozer coming i
can't get over that one i wish we could
look into that story i know
i'm too afraid to google it now because
i don't what if somebody out there
google that damn story
i want to know what happened to that guy
so did you
get another pet after that i haven't you
haven't now
and is it because you don't want to go
through that again yeah
it's really it is but is it the loss of
the pet you don't want to go through
again or
all of it the maintenance the hey i'm
back on the road someone's got to take
care of it
if it gets sick this has to happen or
was it
a little bit of both but it's mostly the
loss because i know that
i'm in a position to have someone take
care of my cat if i'm
or a dog when i'm out of town i'm in a
position to
you know take it to a boarding but like
everyone is we can all figure it out
and i'm sure that it would be nicer to
rescue an animal than just be selfish
and not have to put one down but
it it it just feels um
weird like i'm betraying him or
something it's really funny
that's not pathetic i get it i do get it
yeah so we haven't and
and my husband's not a huge he loves
animals but he is very
we he travels a lot for work too and
he's out of town like half the month
after the year
so he's just like how how would we do
this
and um so i haven't but a lot of it is
my own just like oh and then i just had
a friend had to go through and put her
dog down and i'm like oh god i just know
the pain and the it's just the worst
feeling in the world and i don't want to
put myself through that again
so when you had to put your cat down or
someone else's cat that became your cat
down
did did that death and dying
and you know just final moment bring
back
the feelings that you felt when he
passed away yeah it definitely did and
it made me
i felt like
kind of relieved in a sense of of of
you know if there's any sort of
spiritual thing where they get to hang
out or whatever
right together or the rainbow bridge or
whatever they run around
but also just felt like okay i did i
took care
i you know it was because he said please
you know he didn't know he was going to
die but when i took his cats in he was
like please be very careful please make
sure they don't get out i mean little
disease no one got
eaten by a coyote but or maybe he does
know wait so you had him before
he passed yeah i was watching them
so i had them in my yeah because his you
didn't take him because he died you had
already had them
yeah so his roommate didn't want
it either was allergic or didn't want
them or something so i had
so he said until i i don't even know how
long i was supposed to keep them to be
honest because it did
he he was basically kind of crashing
with this roommate and he was looking
for his own place
so when he had his own place he was
gonna take the cats but in the meantime
and i had a roommate at the time who was
like why do we have two
why did i come home and there's two
[ __ ] cats all of a sudden i'm like i
don't know because neil
needed me to watch them and she's like
you haven't [ __ ] that guy before's
cats
[Music]
i mean
uh at least your roommate was honest she
was i mean
that was great she was like oh my god
you got his cat
she was like you're getting the raw end
of this deal yeah
half of it and then you had a you had a
partner for 16 [ __ ] years after that
yeah which and you got close so it's not
like you just did this to
you know because you felt obligated you
actually really cared for this cat yeah
yeah
that's that's huge and i remember there
was a couple there was one time he was
on his
nail when he was still alive was on his
way over and the cats had gotten out
that day i mean apparently i wasn't
great at keeping the cats
inside i like to blame my roommate we
lived in like beechwood canyon and door
you know
no she didn't give a [ __ ] about these
cats she's like sorry the door was open
i guess they got out but um luckily they
came back right before he
visited so i i didn't even tell him i
wasn't like they got out there's you
don't tell anyone you know anything like
that
but so as far as he knows they were both
in good care
when he passed until one
time went into the woods never never
returned
maybe he's living a life a nice life
somewhere you know but yeah the
neighbor's house
just went over there and started kicking
it there was like [ __ ] this place i'm
gonna stay over here
and then it wasn't long after that after
he passed away
and i had these cats that we had someone
break in is my break in your home well
it was basically we were
my friend and i had gone out um my
roommate and i had gone out
we got home and we basically just
fell asleep watching tv on the couch
because i mean at this point we had a
one bedroom
so we should we had like a trundle bed
it was the saddest you know we she was
like lucy and desi sleeping together it
was really pathetic
so a lot of times one of us would sleep
in top bed and whoever she had the top
which actually is kind of [ __ ] up
because it was my dad gave me that bed
and you're on the most uncomfortable
yeah the most uncomfortable and
this was fun i kind of i forgot about
that god i really like let her get away
with whatever
but so a lot of times we would follow or
one of us would fall asleep on the couch
or whatever we
and we'd been drinking we were out we
fell asleep and i guess one of
i guess one of us didn't lock the door
but
we thought we did and luckily she woke
up first there was somebody
opening the door to the apartment and
she woke up and she just dove she
ran to the door and the person backed
out which i don't know if i would have
had that instinct or not i
i i think i would just cry in a corner
and let someone
um but her instinct was to run and since
he wasn't all the way all the way and he
backed out
and then we locked the door and we
called 9-1-1 and my friend
is she's looking out the window and he's
just standing there
with his dick in his hands no yeah and
he's just standing there and he's like
he we the window was kind of cracked so
we could kind of hear him and he was
like i know you ain't [ __ ] your
boyfriend yet
heard you might need something
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i might be barking up the wrong tree but
i'm right here with my dick in my hand
i very could have easily heard me
talking about it at the bar
men don't i don't know any man who could
sit here and say
they've ever had some woman try to break
in their home with their just [ __ ] all
out like it doesn't i don't know if that
happens
mathematically it has to but there's got
to be like five of those stories in the
history of those stories yeah
this is a guy trying to break into your
home with his dick already out
yeah and he said [ __ ] when she saw him
outside he actually said he goes uh i
was just jerking off
like that like oh sorry you interrupted
me kind of
basically walk in and jerk off into two
girls sleeping no
yeah that's something i was getting
something on him i feel like yeah and
then the worst part was
i was on the phone while she was looking
at him and she you know we're both
panicking
and she's like oh my god he's jacking
off and i yell into 9-1-1
he's jacking up i wish we could hear
that
it exists somewhere you know it all
exists somewhere
you know it does
oh my god and then he took off luckily
and the cops came like three
hours hours later yeah they don't you
know there's a bigger problems i guess
i was like what if he they don't know
what if he came back yeah seriously but
at the time that was it was not long
after
he came back but he came he came and
went
we really ruined that guy's plan but he
probably wouldn't hurt anyway yeah you
two [ __ ]
so he was so blasey about it i was just
jacking off okay
sorry that's when you know they're
psychotic yeah when they're super casual
about the craziest [ __ ] like
yeah i'm just breaking into your home to
jerk off
like yeah we got a problem with it yeah
and i didn't have anywhere to go i just
remember thinking this wasn't long after
neil had died so i was like i don't have
anywhere to go i don't have anywhere
else to stay
at night you know and and my friend of
course she had a boyfriend
and she was started staying the night in
his house just like screw you
[ __ ] you and that cat yeah so she just
started staying in his house
and um i just
i just remember thinking again no
luckily no but i just remember thinking
like god it would be nice to have
someone yeah to be with right now or
some
another place to stay and it wasn't too
long after him so i was like oh if neil
was around
i could stay with him but um i wonder if
his girlfriend would care
all night she wasn't there can you
believe that letter i think i still have
it's too i think i saved it yeah
because i felt like i'm sure yeah i know
i do
i definitely saved it because i just it
i don't know it was like the only
thing i had sort of left of him in a way
but also
it was evidence that he had a girlfriend
if it ever came up i don't know it was
just
a lot of [ __ ] break-ins i had a good
friend of mine she
um called me one morning and she said
that
she had a roommate another girl i knew
and um her name's christy so she went to
work
or i'm sorry her roommate rachel went to
work first and when christy got up she
said she sat down at the kitchen table
was having a little bowl of cereal and
looked over
um and saw that the screen had been
pushed in
and then so she texts the roommates like
hey you didn't see the screen like this
like you know why you leaving [ __ ] like
that the door's unlocked you just left
with the door unlocked she's like
no i didn't and she's like huh and so
between the time that her roommate left
for work early in the morning
and the time she woke up someone had
come in
thinking that the place was empty saw
her
freaked out bailed okay a week later
rachel's now home sleeping on like a
saturday morning she wakes up and
there's a gardener
looking in the window [ __ ] jerking it
and he was one of the landscaping crew
um employees that would do like several
of the buildings in the area and we
lived in sherman oaks at the time
yeah and this guy ends up coming in
and not knowing they kept encasing the
place for a while and everything and
then just
same [ __ ] like then they never had a
problem again but i was like
[ __ ] i guess if you i guess it's like a
one and done you just sort of go i'm not
gonna show my face there
it's a one and done for you but that
person's probably doing that to who
who until they get caught probably you
know they never do
never the police aren't coming for
unless you get them and hold them there
and they'll be you know if you can hold
if anyone out there can hold an intruder
for three hours
you might be able to [ __ ] get the
cops and i'll be out yeah i started
sleeping
with pepper spray under my pillow after
that and um
we didn't have air conditioning in that
apartment so
i woke up it like one time it was you
know two o'clock in the morning or
something and i was like oh
there's someone in here because that i
had one of those like tall
fans at the end of my bed and i was like
there's somebody [ __ ] in here
and i no i unloaded my nephew into the
fan right back on you
are you [ __ ] serious luckily it
didn't go
just spraying the whole [ __ ] roof
i've accidentally hit it in a car with a
friend just jerking around one time and
it [ __ ] filled the whole car eyes
were broke we were coughing and gagging
i can't imagine having it
blown right back into my face i think i
i guess it got kind of spread out to
where it wasn't so bad i wasn't like
blinded or something but i definitely
was like oh my god
i mean that's another moment maybe i
need to live with someone else
you know someone that'll stay around
because if you wake up and pepper spray
yourself out of
fear from a fan panic from a fan shit's
not going great
yeah so did you have any other serious
relationships between
um this guy and john or were you like
put off by you said maybe like yeah
they're gonna leave anyway so was it
more
casual did you find yourself afraid to
commit no
i not really i i mean i definitely i had
a couple
you know a few several months to maybe a
year relationships nothing
nothing where i was living with anyone
or being like too serious with anyone
um a couple where i probably
either either the person was more into
me or i was more into them a couple of
those relationships where i was like
okay well this isn't
going very far um and then
and then i had a there was a guy that i
dated on and off for five years he's the
one i ended up moving in with
um that that i had my cat still then
and um so he got to meet your cat he got
to meet my character
he didn't deserve it he didn't deserve
the time
but he he was really the only sort of
longer term
because um it was part
fear of somebody just you know of
getting too close to someone and them
disappearing and then part
my own just [ __ ] and immaturity
probably of not
being knowing when i was ready or
it wasn't until when i met my husband it
was like oh that's
you knew yeah quickly quickly we met
in um in person like we had talked for
about
two months just texting and and we had
never spoken on the phone
and how did you meet so he plays
football he plays
i know at the time okay i mean he played
for the seahawks at the time
and and he did you even like football
did you give a [ __ ] about football i did
i mean i'm i'm a huge baseball fan
but i've i've never had especially
growing up in arkansas i had i was more
of a college
football fan i didn't really have who's
closest to you i guess razorbacks
nfl yeah nfl would be dallas for the
chiefs and
most of my family was like chiefs or
dallas so
i mean i liked it but i didn't pay
enough attention to have a team and then
when i met him he was it was funny it
was actually the year
they won the super bowl and ross
matthews you know ross matthews yeah
so he's a big seahawks fan and he was
down on the sidelines during a
championship game
and john went up to him and he was like
hey do you know sarah colonna don't you
guys work together
because we had been doing the panel on
on chelsea at the time
and he was like yeah i i know and he
said i have a crush on her do you want
to
hook us up and ross was like um maybe
we'll see why don't you see if you can
win the game or whatever he said too
once you get out there and punt the ball
first bro you got some other [ __ ] you
need to
focus on how did you focus on her
[ __ ] we got a ring to win
like i mean i know you have a little
time off in quarters but come on buddy
we're trying to win a championship
that's great
oh and then ross tweet texted me
afterwards that he was like this guy
is gonna he's gonna tweet you and
so he knew of you from television
yeah but you did not know of him at all
no at all no i didn't no um
okay yeah so he makes the first move
then yeah
and all right he basically said he he
wrote me and was like you know i
well it's funny when he wrote me i
looked and i already followed him and i
realized he had
messaged like tweeted me or something
before
i mean it's just so i don't pay that
much i know i was like oh it's verified
i guess i'll follow him yeah
it's cute you know um and i just
remember thinking
i don't the last person i would want to
date is an athlete i mean there are you
know
i had um hooked up with a baseball
player and it was
he's just it was just gross everything
about it was gross i mean it was fun but
it was just i was just like oh this is
gross
because it was i set myself up for it i
went
i basically flew we had been messaging
and
and texting and then i basically flew to
see him play
and thought we were gonna go out on a
date but we didn't we just
we were just in his hotel room and then
and then i saw myself out it was you
know it was just
[Laughter]
and this was like you know i had been i
had
i felt confident in myself at the time
that you need taken care of or i'm
pretty solid with that bro
mine's on its way out if you'd like to
get me give me a new one
yeah it was just one of those it was oh
it was a whole lead up but i flew
to see him and remember thinking like
it was fun and i was like i'm i'm
i don't know i just felt like i was
doing something a little bit out of my
comfort
zone and hooking up with this athlete
and all this stuff
that it just yeah i did not feel i did
not feel
great afterwards i mean not it wasn't
like i was down on myself i was just
like that was
that was disappointing i was hoping for
more yeah i thought he would be fun
and we would like hang out and and he
seemed like a fun person and
his persona was very fun but he was just
more of like a dick
and that's i should have figured that
out but that so i was sort of
not really ready to hit the reply button
on
another athlete hitting on me on twitter
yeah but ross was like no i fi
like i follow the seahawks this guy's
been on there for years he's i've never
heard a bad word about him everyone on
the team loves him
so i said all right and then we started
talking and he was just he's very funny
like he just led with
his personality and um and then we kept
talking and he
he said you know we've we moved on to
phone numbers as
as you do from twitter it's all so
stupid but
he uh he said you know i i have a kind
of a big game to play
the super bowl was that week and he said
um but i'd like to take you out when
we're done
when i'm back and then they won that
night
and he was texting me all night
after the win photos of him holding the
trophy
photos in the locker room photos of the
party afterwards and it just felt like
he was trying to let me know that he
because we'd been talking for
you know a bit at this point and it felt
like he was trying to let me know like
hey i'm
i'm interested in you this is i'm not
out doing i mean if there's any point
you're gonna run around new york with
your dick out it's after you win a super
bowl right
and i mean that's a reason to bust into
somebody's apartment with your dick
out not just
some rando sorry i just won the super
bowl
that would have been a much better call
he just won the super bowl
it's a partner i think
yeah that was when i realized he was um
[Music]
not like the other person that i had
encountered in a bit of a different
personality
and i just from there it just sort of
escalated he came to
he came to l.a in february i think that
year
to he took his family to disneyland as
you do after the super bowl
and then he took an uber up to studio
city where i was living at the time and
took me out to dinner yeah
how nice is that all right yeah and it
was just right we've been talking for so
long and
he was just so like he brought me on our
first date he brought me a box of all
his favorite [ __ ] like
this is my favorite candy this is my
favorite movie this is my favorite he
had a bobble head of
uh i think someone from the mariners
like he's a big baseball fan too he had
all this stuff in a box and he was
and how hilarious would it be if it was
the guy you hooked up with
[Laughter]
throw it over the balcony
it was not him thank god but yeah i
i he brought me all that stuff to tell
me um
now these are my favorite things i can't
wait to learn what all yours are
yeah that's and i was like that's a move
you know and um
he's just super supportive and funny and
sort of broke that wall down in me of
thinking that you couldn't
really there was i have i had pretty
serious trust issues with people and i
was always right like the guy that i was
living with before
was he and it wasn't about me he was
very much he was just so insecure that
he had to
text or email any facebook any
anyone he could he just he needed that
attention and
maybe it would never went further than
that i have no idea but
they were very inappropriate for someone
especially in any relationship let alone
and i i mean i i can break your password
like nobody's [ __ ] business like i
broke his password
fast
[Laughter]
and i i got into his facebook and
found a lot of very inappropriate
things and he you know basically
blamed me for it and i think this isn't
this isn't how this is supposed to work
and that was another reason it was very
easy for me
to end that relationship and just feel
relief and
i swear to god with john i am like you
his
phone i could give a [ __ ] about his
phone his when it
when he gets a text or something and
that's how it should be and i feel like
yeah i know there are people who are
over jealous for other reasons and
they're always looking for something
but for me that the two times that it
has happened to me it has been because i
was
dead on correct yeah and i could tell by
their behavior i could tell something
was going on and then of course they
want to blame you um but with my husband
i'm
i mean he's i've had to ask him for his
passcode when he was driving or
something he's like i've given it to you
i'm like yeah i don't need to remember
it
i don't i've never looked at all i'm the
same way i'm not looking at your [ __ ]
phone
i got better [ __ ] to do i know i'm just
gonna get pissed off if i'm right i'm
just going to get mad
you know i don't want to be right oh
well if i'm right i want to know
but i luckily with him i don't
have you know i mean for all i know he's
running around
sherman oaks at night putting his dick
in the window
but he hides it really well and yeah
makes me feel secure
people don't recognize himself good good
news yeah
like oh he usually has his helmet on on
tv so nobody knows it's
him all right so we're about there and i
want to ask you what i ask
every guest that comes on for the first
time uh advice you would give to your 16
year old self what would you say to 16
year old sarah
well lock your door when you get home
from the bar
yeah and if you know anyone that uh
works around bulldozers
tell them keep a look keep a
over their shoulder ah this has been fun
i i don't know if we've had people talk
about
the loss of uh a pet like that and and
but also how it ties into this
what a tragic story i'm sorry that's
[ __ ] sucks
well thank you i mean that really does
suck to know that
that you were there there's absolutely
nothing you could have done
but to know you were there and at that i
mean you really are driving that point
home though you know what i mean just to
make sure i think about it
i mean if you could have just said hang
on a second let me tie my shoe real
quick here and then we'll walk
anything no i'm just kidding um please
plug
promote everything again uh yes please
sarahcalona.com
has the links to all the tour dates that
will and be updated
and um my books and like i said watch
shameless watch insatiable and i do have
a podcast
it's about lifetime movies um
and making fun of them so it's a little
bit niche but it's super fun and it's
called
are you my podcast awesome thank you
very much this was a lot of fun
uh as always ryan sickler on all social
media ryansickler.com we will talk to
you all next week
[Music]
you